find an organization that you can get
behind when you start having a bit of an
ability to have an effect whether it be
monetary or just by virtue of showing up
when someone says do you want to help a
kid a child smile or have a nice
afternoon if they're having a hard time
and it was just a no-brainer for me well
it's this is literally close to my heart
because it's close to my son's heart he
had two operations at Children's
Hospital open heart surgeries and they
went great and we just feel very lucky
to be in a city that has such a great
hospital and also this Hospital trains
doctors and nurses to go to other
children's hospitals not just around the
country but all around the world so it's
particularly important that we support
this one you know Children's Hospital
Los Angeles is a great organization they
do wonderful things for kids from all
around the world they see over 600 000
kids a year from all around the world
and they just do such a great thing and
I got involved when I was working with
CBS
we came to the hospital the actors from
my show and handed out toys to some kids
and just kind of opened my eyes to the
place I wasn't really aware of it and
once I became aware of it I just was so
moved and so
you know just some of these kids have
gotten dealt such an awful hand in life
and they really make a difference you
know Children's Hospital Los Angeles
really makes a difference